معرض فلا تزال منقسمه الى ثلاث فتل مختلفه
توجهات جبهه الخلاط الوطني الذي يتزعها
حسب النهضه الحزب الدستوري الحر بقياده
عبير موسى وايضا الاحزاب واليسريه اذا
غليان سياسي في تونس ترافقه حقيقه ازمه
اقتصاديه حدث عن من البلاد فاقمها تعثر
المفاوضات الحاسمه مع صندوق النقل الدولي
للحصول على قرض بنحو مليارين دول العرب
مظاهر الازمه الاقتصاديه واضحه الى حد ما
ابرزها تباطؤ النمو الى اقل من ثلاثه
بالمئه وارتفاعه البطاله الى اكثر من 15%
فيما تزدادوا مستويات الفقره التي دفعت
اثنين وثلاثين الف التونسيه الى الهجره
بحرا نحو ايطاليا بشكل غير قانونيه عن
عشرين اثنين وعشرين ناس كما يواجه
التونسيون تدهورا حادا في قدرته اشترى ايه
ما تضخم تجاوز العشره بالمئه
نقصا في المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه على
غرار الحليب والزيت الطبخ